welcome to this video a beautiful mind a
beautiful night this is some e m letcha
right yep much here we go Queens gambit
something like that yeah a slob I
normally do this and we probably had
games with this with a slide before I
don't remember but probably yeah black
can take on f3 or 97 this is the
principal choice after year for this e5
or you can take first yep he obviously
knows his stuff okay here why it doesn't
have much at all but ok we have
forgotten how this is played Queenie to
is from the room right go to d3
hmm okay it looks quite okay probably he
says something bad happening to me him
don't see it at the moment hmm I'm
keeping you five but may probably you
can just play Quincy seven sure maybe I
play a four by the end I know
hmm not sure what you should do yeah
this is the move this is a move that I
of course always also thought of but if
I casts a long it will lead to a mess
this is clear but this is the problem
move that may be Queen B 6 can be done
but I have stuff like f4 really keeping
the material and asking them how is he
going to how is it going to to justify
all of it with at five but my own king
is of course problem as well and still
night a form this Queen B for probably
and forth probably the the issue yes not
a 3m
yeah maybe f4 f5 is also just not so
great
I'm wondering what that Miriam castle
long but it's sort of the only thing
that justifies the whole play even if
it's even if it's crazy okay well some
things don't help him like 93 and as I
can just take on d4 and play Bishop f2
which is just winning I think those
things do not work maybe just long
castles and somehow after f5 find some
or look the eighth okay yeah f5 f5 is
the move I will play that I mean the
summer refutes at all thats cool but I
can just go up c8 actually I know the
night is saying I'm sorry I'm totally
I'm total messier what I'm telling sorry
yeah but then what's the big deal am I
not just winning a piece where's the big
the big idea Bishop c3 this is this that
idea I can also take da tigi 64 g for NC
three hanging yeah let me maybe let
stand Queen g5 check
beat eggs
okay it could you add bc3 quinchu Quinn
check that's just a good position for
white let's let's do that check just to
keep it simple approach maybe I have
something better with King takes really
hmm I don't believe that guarantee a fat
Queen g5 check it's the only only move
and then Queen d2 is just good for watch
the this is the the no-nonsense approach
where I should just be a lot a lot
better
now I have a pawn and and just the
fantastic position so let's have a look
we should be 29 to h6 and problem
okay I'm pushing back yes night on age
six and this is all not I'm not working
very well maybe a four for Bishop b3 and
then a five yep for Bishop e3 this pawns
are totally killing him a 5 + f5 cannot
develop anything here
maybe g6 or something yeah that is some
relatively speaking but ok here i have
to go to g8 you get to activate your
bishop maybe to e6 but i can try to
prevent it yeah this this is ok
ya know move just going to win b7 he's
almost stalemated him check
some some way to go from made
time warning ok check rook takes his
sick son should be should be quite good
check check for f7 oh come on check
black resigns yeah this was a very
tricky opening very tricky opening play
I don't really remember I have analyzed
this of course but Queen d3 is the norm
oof actually this half I don't know it
looks very very tricky I thought I
thought maybe this is right but very
problematic castles long now that
whenever he takes he has to reckon with
F for this move or with possibly queen
age 5 which is a bit probable problem
because it cannot play f6 so it's not
easy went here and then f4 ok well the
computers at least at first liking it
for white and says long castles is good
ok this is what you played ok after that
i'm winning with the game continuation
and that's what's it's good so I saw
some things correctly so but still after
a fire for this black supposed to play
Bishop me too hmm it's a relief what way
ok and then you're going to take him I
see ok
that's not working at all so I can take
him Queen takes Knight takes hmm yeah
that's very unclear and this is what he
did check check and he I'm just winning
right yeah okay so i think it it was a
good decision that i was I wasn't
totally sure yeah after Bishop takes
what the best is but this is just like
just goes out to keep some I keep my
advantages I keep this this structure
here and I get Queens traded which helps
quite a not my king is the weak link in
my position okay well thanks for
watching